gratulations on season two thank you so
exciting you know you get to know this
character you get to know the cast all
throughout season one are you excited to
delve into season two kind of having
like the confidence of knowing your
character now absolutely I mean the
biggest thing was just we got just
thrown into the deep end
half of our cast didn't get added until
like the week of production so it was
just this crazy and then me being my
first lead and all of these different
moving parts and now it's like okay it
worked now we can kind of go in and like
have the initial anxieties sort of set
aside and there will be a whole new list
of anxieties I'm sure but really take it
each day what would you say at the top
three things that fans should keep in
mind and know about going into season
two top two things that fans should keep
in mind remember from Season one Oh hmm
I mean that's tricky we don't know too
much about season two and then you know
Dick Wolf gives such little character
development in each episode so that a
show can last for twenty seasons and so
I think we're just gonna keep chipping
away at that we definitely closed a book
at the end of season one so we're
excited to see you know how we're gonna
kind of open this new one and who's
gonna get you know the the big sort of
storyline through the thing and kind of
feel like that but I mean just remember
Maggie and always relationship where
it's going and a lot of people wanted it
to go romantic but I feels a little
insensitive it's so so you because I've
seen fans say that online yeah but we
just found out who killed her husband
Rick at ten minutes ago I think because
the chemistry between both of you so
good it is it's amazing on and off
screen we have so much fun together
I'm can't believe how lucky I got Missy
with me so like it's just it's been
great what do you think the magic is
between o and Maggie like why does that
dynamic work so well well I'd like to
think that it it
you know stems over from sort of his
background in his upbringing and um what
we're trying to do with the character is
sort of he is the supportive you know
the supportive man to to the stronger
female character that's his lead and and
that's always kind of in my case I have
a lot of older women in my family so
it's like they're the driving force and
I'm the the yes-man and like getting to
kind of bring that on camera not being
sort of a dominant male character and
getting to be a supportive one
especially as an Arab and then bringing
that into you know on screen as
protagonist for the first time it's
really nice to kind of stray away from
negative stereotypes on sort of all
fronts with the Muslim or Arab man and
so we get to kind of bring like a new
sort of innocent light the friendly kind
of kind of vibe which I think people are
enjoying so firstly obviously it's a
very you know you're dealing with some
serious subjects in this show how
intense was season one it was the most
intense thing ever
we each each of these episodes their
movies and where they're trying to you
know elevate the production of the show
to sort of have this new thing that can
differentiate from the long order and
like you know kind of bring it into this
this um you know this new time in
television where we're getting a little
darker and you know we're seeing sort of
cinematic elements kind of brought to
television which is really nice and are
deep he's so good at that and she's
awesome and um but yeah I mean it's it's
crazy you you start with 13 episodes and
you don't know if you're gonna go so you
go you know as hard as you can on that
great night and you're okay right
are we even gonna be able to finish and
yeah scheduling and all of these things
I mean it was just such a learning curve
but it was so nice to have Missy kind of
there cuz she definitely helped me out a
lot with with all that stuff and that's
yeah so it worked out we got out we got
out of the race and I think season two
is gonna hopefully I mean you know
everyone says season one's the the most
difficult one so
we'll see if that's true would you say
miss he's like the calming force on set
yeah I mean she's just she knows what
she's doing I mean and just kind of what
she brings to the table is so far beyond
just an actress on the show so it's nice
to especially with you know show like
this where redic
trust his team so much and you know he's
like don't mess it up and so it's great
to have because I was thinking you know
when I was testing and I'm with
actresses and some of them were were
green you know so it would be their
first lead like mine and after the fact
I was like whoa I mean that would have
been insane if it was to no actress
because without her sort of like you
know knowing kind of the cadence of of
how things were supposed to go I don't
know if it would have made it wow that's
awesome let's talk about the spin-off
FBI most wanted
yes is it a little wild that after
season one your shows already getting a
spinoff yeah I mean on paper it's
frickin awesome you know it's like how
what more could you ask for but it is
really exciting because it just makes
the whole FBI world a little bit bigger
and a little bit sort of more kind of
like cemented and official and real when
you do kind of see all these moving
parts and it's it's crazy because it is
a bureau or sort of this department that
has all these moving parts but you kind
of just live with me and Maggie through
the whole story but now realizing that
we're solving a crime that is you know
pretty intense and massive on a big
scale but there's also you know two
hundred other ones that are happening at
the same moment so sort of bring that to
the thing because at the end of it were
just trying to show you know the
audience the scale of the FBI what they
really do behind these closed doors that
have been kind of no closed for such a
long time and yeah just to represent
them and like in every aspect so it's
great to kind of grow the family we're
really excited about it well and last
question with Dana leaving yes the end
of season one how's that gonna shake up
the team how do you think it was season
two but I mean
it's gonna be great I you know I
everyone hopes to be on a show as long
as possible but you know one way or
another things sort of happened the way
they do but it's great I mean I get
getting to work on this show I get to
work with I mean in season one already
there was probably 200 guest stars you
know no 100 co-star ISM and whatever so
you get to meet all these actors and
work with these different people and I
got to work with Connie and then Cielo
and so it's like I'm just getting so
much experience and so much sort of
knowledge and that's that like the more
the merrier bring it you know bring it
almost see what happens I think you're
doing your dream job yeah they should be
able to do it like this is it's good
fine I think let's just keep going this
rule